[Musique]
on vient y croyez vous qu'il y ait de
pâte à puch le faux trompez pas notez
bien sur vos droits drm wada pas de
retour
attention il me manque un
[Musique]
quel beau soleil ce que les biens et
demain je ferai tout monté à toi de
jouer et patinent à toi bien sûr vous
vous amusez vous moi je passe mon temps
à faire la vaisselle matin midi et soir
qu'à raison c'est injuste pata truc de
pata truc j'ai trouvé le truc que
personne n'entre dans la maison
[Musique]
dans ma boîte ce que kathak lointain
travail entre eux tapis vert que brave
dérange riz reste aussi basique
[Musique]
18 ça fait dix-huit je retiens 2,16 et
puis 3 et 5 sur 12
ça fait ça fait que je me suis trompé
alors 10 puis 8
ça nous fait 18 5 et 8
ça te tapes non merci mais mais qu'est
ce que tu fais là toi tu m'espionne
retourne au jardin que je ne te
retrouves pas dans mes jambes quand je
reviendrai je mens pas nouveau
[Musique]
et
assez fermée à clé non je vous ouvrirait
que j'aurai fini et par an ah c'est pas
drôle et moi je m'ennuie bourama
accessoires merci chiante et soir vers
19h foot
j'aimerais pourquoi j'ai pas encore bien
faire la vaisselle pas ouais je parle
conduite personnes 13 ans rugby n'ouvre
pas ses portes
nous allons tous à l'hôtel et nous
ferons payer la note
oh la la qu'est ce que tu avais l'année
du don
on
les filles et moi faire un nom après le
dîner
atx ou lamar
et voilà mais j'étais inquiète une
caisse mais c'est une machine à laver
perfectionner à porter les assiettes et
les verres vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir est de corvée de vaisselle
bada ou plus comme ça
[Musique]